i i had an absolutely [ __ ] amazing
time at this wedding i do think that
indian weddings are the best weddings
i've been thinking about this a lot i
have been to
and i'm not saying this for pandering
reasons i think they are the best
weddings and i
and this is why um okay
expectation as long as your reality
exceeds the expectation
you think it's an amazing time yeah
right the cool thing about india wedding
especially is like a white person or
non-indian that's going into it right
is outside of my interactions with you
yeah
my only interactions with indians are in
like the highest levels of
professionalism right right
a doctor don't be joking around with me
that much if you're a doctor
a dentist don't be kidding around don't
show too much personality
fix me bro yeah so you see like this
muted version of indians
right it's always in some sort of
professional setting they're not being
that silly because oftentimes the jobs
they choose are very high stakes
yeah you're the ceo of a company don't
be kidding around guy who runs google
make sure to google google's don't got
time for that no more time
right and then outside of that it's a
very
uh tightly knit community so there's not
that many people from the outside that
are gonna get access to it right
so the first time a lot of non-indians
see
indians actually be indian yeah is at
the wedding right we assimilate
everywhere else
everywhere else hey what do you do we'll
figure it out we'll keep our stuff as
much as we can but we're going to
assimilate to what you do
indian wedding you're going to
assimilate to us yes and
what's so interesting is the
assimilation process is nothing
yeah we're way more similar yeah you
like to party your asses off
drink dance and the cool thing about it
is the dancing
is about enjoyment not romance
yeah men dance with men yeah 100 old
people dance with young people kids
everybody
was like a rave it was like just move
your body remove your body whatever you
got it's like burning man like a little
yeah
i literally thought of it but at no
point in time we were like oh i think
they're trying to hook up or that kind
of stuff like that it wasn't sexualized
it was just everybody go have a good
time i don't even think about that yeah
i'm telling you man a really cool aspect
was
that when you see everybody dancing
first of all indians can bust it down
but there are also indians that can't
but it seems like nobody's insecure to
dance if you're a white person you're
not dancing in no black wedding
and if you aren't sure you're not doing
a latin wedding you're not making fool
of yourself at a black or like there's
no line dance where you got to get it
right
it's just good have fun that's how you
get it right if you're having fun you're
doing it right if you're not at least
from the
only lightnings we have i didn't even
hadn't even done this punjabi thing is
called a real goody at the end where you
just get in line everybody's runs around
the room like a train
yeah that's it there's no steps if you
don't know the cupid shuffle you don't
know the [ __ ] you out you look like a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you could run in a line man hands
in the air like in the air
one of the things about dancing i think
it's most uncomfortable for people is
they don't know what to do with their
arms
yeah so even if they are to step in
they're like do i snap do i clap they
don't know and then
you guys just have it built in up in the
[ __ ] area
people don't know what do you think this
[ __ ] is black people not know what to do
with their [ __ ] hands
so they had to build it into the dance
the macarena is all what do i do with my
hands
right i thought that was floating like
trying to
yeah that's what i thought i told every
white person i was uncomfortable to
dance you just gotta shrug
and then do something with it just shrug
on beat and then just do whatever you
want and it all flies so we're watching
everybody just like let loose and again
i can't speak for you guys but that was
my experience and i was like oh
[ __ ] like i don't have to feel insecure
everybody is either looking amazing or
making a fool of themselves because it's
all in the
in the guise of fun as long as you're
having fun you're doing the right thing
yeah um also food yeah
indian food is perfect wedding food yeah
eating food is is stews yeah right
like if you go to like wedding usually
wedding food sucks
yeah i didn't realize that it sucks like
and it's like
you don't want to make 300 steaks at one
time
dude you don't want to make 300 chicken
parms at one time
you know what i mean that's like
lunchroom food for kids like that's the
reason why
it sucks when you go to public school
you get like this little bag lunch it
sucks because you have to make
300. the indian food is built for it
yeah the longer it sits in the stew
the better the better it gets yeah so
we're having like this delicious food
everybody's having a great time i mean
it was just
it was just amazing think about because
my parents when they would
when like i have all these indian kids i
grew up with a few of my grooms when you
met
i just their my our parents were friends
had kids every weekend we go to each
other's house
they would just move the furniture in
the living room and just put on music
and dance
that's what a party was to me i didn't
know you like went out to clubs and [ __ ]
like that yeah and there was always this
thing they would do that i didn't
realize
i do it now all the time if you're not
dancing they just pull you in and make
you dance it doesn't [ __ ]
there is no judgment there is no are you
good or are you not just move your body
have fun that's all we want yeah and i
didn't even realize that until you said
it just now that's what i do when i saw
you guys at the bar on friday
i was like where the [ __ ] are they i
went looking for you and then i was like
every one of you i was like
get your ass on the floor yeah and then
anybody that was insecure i would just
yank them in or shove them into the
center and just be like just go okay so
you know my girl is like
she hates attention yeah right like she
does not very [ __ ] attention
she she was dancing in the middle of the
circle yes that does not happen
unless she feels incredibly she would
never do that
she was like this is actually this is
what she said she's like there's
actually great practice for our wedding
i'm like you wouldn't dance in the
circle
yeah so it was just really cool to see
that environment and that doesn't exist
everywhere
yeah i didn't even realize that and now
you guys got something i was trying to
think what are the best way or why are
indian weddings so fun
and i was thinking it's just any culture
where family is really important the
wedding is probably fun i've heard greek
weddings are fired interesting because
it's a big family culture italian
weddings are probably fire because it's
family and it's food
so probably fire but then indian
weddings we just india if you go to
india it's just matte colors everywhere
everywhere it's the best wedding man
also just the idea that like you want
people to embrace your culture and dress
up yeah like it was [ __ ] halloween
for us
like we were going out here we're trying
to match it like look at these things we
kept them right we got sneakers
so many people wanted to keep the bug
the turban i was surprised yeah you kept
people no you absolutely can't yeah just
don't like throwing on the ground or
whatever we don't know mistreated but
everybody was like no i want to keep
mine
that wasn't indian the indians are like
now you can have it you you'll hit this
[ __ ] every once in a while when you say
something nope
no the pug was fire dude the pumps fire
and it was cool going to the
good doorway good work yeah gurdwara
this guy was telling me that um
if you're if you're hungry anywhere in
the world just go to a gurdwara yeah
they'll feed you like they were feeding
like the soldiers that
they were fighting against yeah yeah
yeah like like crazy
yeah it's a big thing it's called lunger
and it's like a big like practice for
six which is like we feed people who
need food
like even if we're beefing what's that
what's the actual name of the golden
temple i forget the barcelona
i'm on the sub they have they feed like
50 000 people today
that's crazy yeah um yeah i mean it was
just really beautiful to like learn
about that because we were in where the
ceremony was
uh that being said that's my last
religious ceremony at a wedding i'm not
i'm not going to do it
i'm not going to do any more well yeah
i'm i'm sick you became sick
i'm sick mark bentham can i tell you
something sick this is something really
important
another thing indians won't do at their
wedding this is really important they
won't tell you any of the rules so
you told us dress up in suits on friday
we dress up in suits on friday we come
saturday
all the indians are in tuxedos and suits
and we're the only ones
dressed in indian outfits yeah you know
what
you could wear that's why i said when
you were like
hello we're looking like [ __ ] we
look like we're making fun of the people
there
not dude not at all it is you can wear
western or eastern that's why when you
ask
why did you guys go western we would
have went eastern with you guys on
friday and here's
why a lot of it if you go to a lot of
indian weddings you can't really wear
that suit again
if you wear a suit as a dude you just
mix and match shirt and tie and that's
it
so i don't need it's almost like you
know women need outfits for every
wedding or whatever
like if you wear that outfit again
everybody's like yo you wore that [ __ ]
if i have a suit i have a black suit i
just change out the shirt and tie and
i'm good
right i have to buy a new one of those
every single time i go to a wedding and
so it's like
i've been wearing the same suit for the
last three years every single wedding
your wedding
sweating yeah that's what we do the same
exact thing i have one suit
so it's easy for indian wedding it works
to do both so i'm like i'll just wear
the suit at night
because then i just change out the shirt
and tie i don't have to shop it's
convenience
it's laziness
we're not the only [ __ ] we showed up
basically in blackface we're wearing
brown shirts on saturday night
and i had i was walking in the hallway
and i saw your your cousin who's maybe
the most handsome indian person i've
ever seen in my
gonna be 2.0 and it really bothers me oh
my god it's 2.0
that [ __ ] is so handsome he's
like
3 000. remember when the terminator had
to fight the liquid
he's the liquid he's been here before
what he's
you've met him i wouldn't remember that
i would have remembered we would have
been blown away by that spread that man
on some
booty bread
almost slapped him in his mouth he goes
you excited for tonight i was like keep
staying excited
yeah you clean this [ __ ] off your
stomach
i'm telling you that was that handsome
[ __ ] i was insecure talking to
him bro
yeah it felt uncomfortable and he was in
a tux he goes oh you guys are going with
the traditional attire tonight while i'm
seeing him in the tux i'm like oh this
[ __ ]
got setting us up yeah yeah you set up
something little footage
you set us up at the ceremony at the six
ceremony
you didn't tell me we were gonna be
sitting there for four hours
you